what what do you say we we speak with
Brandon Ingram who had 30 tonight his
fifth 30-point game of the season and he
joins us from Golden One center tonight
where there was no lighting of the beam
because the Pelicans beat the Kings for
the third time this season Brandon
thanks for taking a few minutes with us
we appreciate it yes I appreciate you
hey you guys came into this game with a
record of 11 and 10 could have been a
lot better but one of the issues has
been letting leads get away you had six
losses when you led by double dig what
was the key to keeping that getting that
lead tonight and keeping that lead in
their gym execution you know they came
down to getting defensive stops uh
trying to slow down fox trying to slow
down sabonis and rebounding the
basketball um JV um had a a huge task
today trying to box out sabonis and we
all had to come in and rebound the
basketball and try to push in transition
and get the best shot brand new sha here
you guys got off to a slow start but the
others Murphy and Alvarado gave you guys
a lift in the first half talk about the
importance of the others of the Pelicans
yeah I mean it's a luxury to have we
we've been injured and having Trey
Murphy and Jose back they bring energy
to our team Al also Naji Marshall uh
pushing the pace and transition so um
it's a luxury to have when you have
really really talented guys on the floor
they can come on the floor and make an
impact you know Brandon you do one thing
that's really impressive to me when I
watch you play on offense you make your
move you're going to get to your spot
and just rise up do you think about that
like you you say I'm just going to get
to my spot and rise up and shoot the
ball comfortably is that your mindset
absolutely every single time I know
that's that's my bread and butter um you
know when when shots not falling I can
go to that every single time and I know
I got a good chance of making
that well Brandon one congratulations
and uh one I'm going um I'm talk about
your work ethic in the summertime but
also upset with you because you just he
rents out the whole gym at The Stance
place and no one's allowed to use the
gym for like 8 hours yeah he knows
exactly what I'm talking about but uh if
you go from that work those workouts
that you rent the gym for eight hours
you go to the USA team and now here do
you a lot some guys say it propels them
into the season all of that work or some
guys say they' actually they could they
have to ease into the season what what
do you feel like for
you well um you know in USA I learned a
lot of lessons and um coming back and
again to play against guys that's some
young players that's really really good
in this league it gave me a little head
start on um conditioning for the for for
the NBA and um the start of the season
so um when I came into training camp I
was ready to go um I had some I had some
so slow starts but they've been better
um better and better every single every
single season in this season i' I've had
I had better starts I had a better start
and um I felt good coming out uh playing
with my teammates in training camp and
it led to um regular season games and
hopefully I can keep going my body feels
good and I'm ready to keep it going you
a Vegas guy you like
Vegas I like Vegas I definitely like
Vegas yeah you're going to like it a lot
Thursday night too you're in the uh that
a trick finals trick question like Vegas
not everybody hey hey B I'll meet you at
the roulette table P
out appreciate your time man thank you
much appreciate you man appreciate
it